Це не наукова фантастика, ця техніка
справді працює. Швейцарська компанія Climeworks
використовує вентилятори та спеціальні фільтри,
щоб вибирати з повітря парниковий газ СО2.
Потужність установки - 700 тонн на рік.
Діоксид вуглецю, отриманий у такий спосіб,
подають трубами до прилеглої
теплиці та використовують там як добрива для рослин.
Таким чином зі шкідливих вихлопних газів
отримують товар на продаж, а також
борються зі змінами клімату.
Якщо ми хочемо досягти кліматичної цілі,
а саме ефективно знизити вміст CO2 у повітрі,
то зробити це зможемо лише
якщо вилучатимемо вуглекислий газ
з повітря та вводитимемо його у ґрунт.
Це роблять уже в Ісландії. Ця геотермальна електростанція працює з гарячою парою
з підземного вулкану. З лавових мас
виділяється, зокрема, і СО2,
який, змішуючи з водою, відкладають
у вулканічних породах.
Ця суміш потрапляє сюди, змішується з водою з електростанції
і відкладається на глибині 1-2 кілометри.
Climeworks приєдналася до цієї системи.
Підприємства, що хочуть поліпшити свої показники
викиду вуглецю, можуть скористатися
цим винаходом з фільтрування CO2.
Звичайно, за гроші.
Ми проводимо тести, щоб з'ясувати, якими  мають бути моделі
формування ціни.
Нині це дорожче, ніж буде через 10 років.
Ми хотіли б увійти в діапазон від кількох сотень
до 100 доларів за тонну. Сьогодні це буде поки дорожче.
Ми шукаємо клієнтів, які б зробили з нами
перші і подальші кроки.
Накопичувач СО2 можна використовувати
будь-де у світі, якщо під землею є базальт.
Великий пористий камінь
особливо добре підходить для постійного зберігання
діоксиду вуглецю. На базальт багатий
майже кожен континент. Ось чому засновник Climeworks
переконаний в успіху своєї технології.
Наша мета на найближчі 10 років -
це відфільтрувати 1 відсоток світових викидів.
Це 300 мільйонів тонн. Це дуже, дуже велика кількість,
але цілком реальна.
Гглобальна інженерія, яка за допомогою нових технологій
змінює клімат, лише на початках свого розвитку. Однак перші проекти
вже демонструють, що з її допомогою можна багато
чого досягти.